SO --
>> THANKFULLY THOSE DREAMS NEVER
BECAME REALITY.
>> IN THE MORNING THEY PICKED ME
UP FROM THE PRISON IN AN FSB
CONVOY, PUT ME ON THE PLANE.
DID YOU KNOW WHERE YOU WERE
GOING?
>> I ASKED THE FSB LIKE SECURITY
TEAM THERE, ARE WE GOING TO
TURKEY, AND THEY WERE LIKE, YOU
KNOW, YEAH.
I THOUGHT THAT LIKE MAYBE THE
U.S. EMBASSY IN TURKEY WAS GOING
TO COME PICK ME UP.
I HAD NO IDEA WHAT WAS GOING ON,
AND THESE VANS WERE DRIVING BACK
AND FORTH TO THE JET ON THE
RUNWAY AND MAYBE THAT'S THE U.S.
EMBASSY AND THE FSB WAS LIKE NO,
THAT'S OKAY.
MAYBE THAT'S LIKE THE EMBASSY.
AND SHE SAID HOW DO I KNOW THAT
THAT'S NOT THEM, AND THEY SAID
WE HAVE A MAN THERE IN AMERICA,
AMERICAN JET WILL FLY HERE.
HE WILL LAND NEXT TO US.
WE WILL LEAVE THE PLANE, HE WILL
LEAVE THE PLANE.
YOU WILL CROSS EACH OTHER ON THE
RUNWAY AND GET IN YOUR OWN PLANE
AND WHEN I TOLD HIM THAT I WAS
LIKE NO, THIS GUY HAS TO BE
SCREWING WITH ME, AND I WAS LIKE
REALLY, AND HE SAID YES.
HE SAID IT'S PRETTY COOL, HUH?
HE SAID DO YOU FEEL COOL, AND I
SAID ARE, I DON'T KNOW.
HE SAID YOU SHOULD BECAUSE THIS
PLANE COSTS A BOTH LOAD OF
MONEY.
HE SAID THEY WOULD NEVER FLY US
ON THIS PLANE.
>> AT THIS POINT WERE YOU
ALLOWING YOURSELF TO FEEL HOPE?
>> I WAS STILL AVOIDING THAT,
AND IT WAS DIFFICULT.
>> AN AMERICAN FINALLY DID SHOW
UP.
IT WAS THE TOP DIPLOMAT WITH THE
SPECIAL PRESIDENTIAL ENVOY FOR
HOSTAGE AFFAIRS.
>> SO COLONEL KARSTENS CAME ON,
ROGER KARSTEN FROM SPEHA, AND I
WAS LIKE, MAN WORKS IS THIS
ACTOR THEY SENT ME?
LIKE ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER
COMING ON HERE TO WASTE ALL THE
FSB GUYS AND JUST RESCUE ME, SO
HE CAME AND GOT ON THE JET.
HE SAYS I'M ROGER CARSTENS, I
HAVE TO IDENTIFY YOU, AND I
SAID, YEAH, YOU KNOW, IT'S ME.
I'M TREVOR.
HE DIDN'T RESPOND TO THAT, AND
THEN HE LEFT, AND I WAS KIND OF
LIKE -- LIKE WHAT?
DUDE, SO I WAS LIKE CAN I GO,
AND THE FSB SAID NO, AND I SAID
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
ONE OF THEM LOOKSP-AT-AT ME AND
HE SAYS ARE YOU SURE AMERICA
WANTS YOU BACK?
THEY SENT THEIR GUY OVER TO THE
OTHER JET.
THEY CHECK OUT THEIR GUY.
AND WE -- WE DID THE EXCHANGE,
WALKED PAST KONSTANTIN
YARASHEYKO.
>> A RUSSIAN PILOT IN A 20-YEAR
SENTENCE FOR CONSPIRING TO BRING
$100 MILLION WORTH OF COCAINE
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
>> AND HOW DID HE LOOK VERSUS
HOW DID YOU LOOK?
>> YEAH.
SO HE'S NOT BEEN ON ANY HUNGER
STRIKES THERE, NOT MISSING ANY
MEALS.
>> ONCE ON BOARD THE PLANE,
TREVOR GOT A REAL MEAL.
>> THEY GAVE ME A STEAK ON
THERE, AND THAT WAS THE BEST
THING I'VE EVER ATE IN MY WHOLE
LIFE.
I'LL NEVER FORGET THAT.
>> AND THERE WAS ALSO THE FIRST
PHONE CALL HOME TO MOM AND DAD.
>> THAT MOMENT WAS EXTREMELY
SURREAL.
I DON'T EVEN REALLY REMEMBER
WHAT I SAID THERE.
I THINK I TOLD THEM, YOU KNO